[Music]
I swear we did not call each other I
know just telepathic I honestly changed
my outfit this morning too I was
supposed to wear like all black but
anyway I love your outfit you too Happy
New Year happy New Year yeah do you make
resolutions and then the other question
is do you follow through I do make I do
make resolutions I don't necessarily
follow through what about you the same
yeah yeah I don't make like I think as
the older I get I don't make like
unattainable ones yes so they do I do
make some of them yes but I don't have
like a let's look at the list and see
how I did moment yeah which you know I
just know internally I failed myself a
littleit yeah exactly well let's talk
about this though I didn't know this I'm
musical obviously so anytime I find out
people are musical you were in a band
like when you were a kid it was the
world wait what was it called the world
the world's Patrol kids I wouldn't
exactly call it Musical and I wouldn't
act really call it a band I think you
were the original Captain Planet team
because yeah
yep check it out I mean really really
good graphics and Inc important message
it was about Environmental Protection
and as you see it really had a big
effect you really saved the planet I
know but I yeah we're really doing well
guys um no but I love that though I was
obsessed with I'm not kidding I was
obsessed with Captain Planet I know the
whole song like and I was like you were
the OG Captain Planet teamk I like it
yeah you were you were the Trailblazers
um will farell was her commencement
speaker at Harvard in 20 3 so here is
proof Harvard University's graduating
class of
2003 without a doubt the finest most
talented group of sexual beings this
great land has to
offer I love him so
much like everything about it the
physicality of everything about it do
you remember that day obviously oh my
God so well I remember it so well well
I'm I've been such a big fan of his
forever and then he did this whole bit
where it was like as if he was supposed
to speak at a yacht club and not at
Harvard and he was just like it was so
great and then when I got to meet him on
this I was like do you remember when you
and it was like I didn't realize you
were you were there that day you were
one of the sexual
beings was like aren't we all aren't me
all it was amazing I just thought that
was so funny and then you ended up
working together that's so cool full
circle yeah amazing um your kids are
your kids like impressed with what you
do still my kids are still they're seven
and N they're still kind of impressed
but they're they're teetering on I don't
care my yeah my kids it kind of depends
on what it is like when I was doing Thor
they were like this is the coolest job
ever can you just keep doing this we
want to we a superhero yeah yeah and
they got to be like they got to take a
turn in the harness and fly and do flips
and stuff with the stunt team and they
were like this is just the greatest but
normally I think you you might have the
same they're just like can you just stay
home why are you going to work oh it's
like I've done like sometimes it's like
I've done nothing and then I was on The
Voice with Ariana Grande and they were
like you know her and I was like okay I
was like cool um I thought this was cool
too I'm obsessed with tattoos don't get
them unless you want 20 um they're
they're very addictive but I I heard
that Tao the director of Thor was
actually um tattooing people did you get
one he didn't even ask me I think he
just knows I'm Aude and just didn't even
wait you don't have one I have none I
think I'm like the last Last Man
Standing last woman standing yes would
you get one would you let him do it if
Ty could ask me probably okay um he's
kind of wild though I don't know I
wouldn't trust taica unless I could see
where it was going cuz I feel like if he
did on the back yeah no I don't trust he
didn't give you one no no but I would
totally let him I am addicted I love
them and I think they're memories so I
don't know I saw momento and I guess got
inspired even though that's a really
messed up movie that's a great movie yes
yes it is a good movie yes that was a
look at her new movie made December you
can check it out on Netflix so explain
the movie that is so intense you were
both so great at what you do like it is
incredible and yeah I love the becoming
like you can see that happening in that
scene well Julie Julian is like my
all-time favorite actress i' been
studying everything she does since I I
started working she's just which is kind
of hilarious CU that's what your
character does in the movie Yes in the
movie my character is an actress who's
going to play Julian character in a
movie and so she goes to her to to kind
of learn her character and of course I
was doing that as an actress as well and
I'm slowly kind of becoming her as we
see in the scene where she's teaching me
how to do her makeup and um yeah it was
amazing working with her she's like as
good a human as she is brilliant and
actress so it was just the most fun
experience yeah and her character is
Loosely based off of Mary right Mary Kay
turno Mar yeah yeah it's kind of
inspired by that idea of like a teacher
who has a an illegal um affair with her
student and then ends up having a family
with him and what happens like 20 years
later to them and then my character kind
of gets involved in their lives in a in
a messed up way yeah oh my God it's very
intense it's very cool though so why
this role like why were you interested
in this I thought it was so interesting
about like performance and identity I
think for women especially I think
everyone performs in their lives but for
women especially we're ask to like
perform so many things like how we look
feminine or how even if someone says
something obnoxious to us we're supposed
to like politely smile and politely you
know unless you're trashy yeah and you
just go hell no that was weird
man that's not trashy that's cool say
trashy but so many aspects of what we do
is performative even being absolutely
look at how I'm a mother look at how I'm
a partner um and you almost feel guilt
of if you're not living up to that
standard absolutely and so there's this
concept of like how other people see you
and how you try and meet those
expectations or don't and and I think an
actress kind of exemplifies that because
you're literally performing you know and
you're constantly aware of how people
see you and are observing you so there's
all those like mirror moments in the
movie where you kind of see how the
reflection changes who they are it's
trippy as well cuz you're an actress
playing an actress trying to be come
someone else it's like it's very
Inception it's a lot going on yeah CU
julienne for example was like studying
with a baker how because she plays a
baker in it how to bake the cake so she
was studying she's an actress playing a
character and I'm an actress playing an
actress playing it's like layers exactly
well this is your first for your
production company this is your first
like film right yes so that's important
yeah it was really exciting um like why
this one for your first one I started
Moun a with my partner Sophie Moss who's
one of my great friends and she's an
amazing producer and um this was the
first script that we got really excited
about and then got Todd Hans who's like
the dream of dream directors um to work
with for me um and um yeah it's been
incredible to have this this it's like a
different kind of proud moment because
now it's like from your production
company it's like a different I don't
know do you like that like doing behind
the scenes as well yeah it really feels
like kind of a next stage you know I've
been working since I was 11 years old so
I've been more kind of breaks up the
monotony too doing something different
yeah you kind of take on like I don't
know for you probably having your show
is like where you it's like a different
kind of adulthood to be kind of
creativity too I'm I'm G to like if
there's a problem you don't look to
someone else to solve it you're like I'm
going to I'm the grown up that can be
scary terrifying terrif you're like so
there's no end yeah I got to I got an
answer yeah exactly um but um we just
had Jennifer Garner on here and so she
you own a stock socer team she's a part
of this whole thing she's just like the
most and also hilarious awesome human
yes and knows nothing about soccer
apparently a little bit but I love it
she owned it and I love it but I love
that that you decided to do this was it
inspired by your son yes so I watched so
my son's obsessed with soccer and I
watched him watching the Women's World
Cup when he was seven years old he's 12
now um and he was as excited about the
female players as he was about the male
players like when he was watching you
know men's games and wanted the jerseys
of you know rapino and Alex Morgan and I
was like wow this is culture shifting if
usually everybody watches the men's yeah
yes and if they grow up looking up to
female virtuosic athletes the way they
do to men it's going like be a different
Next Generation so yes so we started
this team Angel City in Los Angeles with
my partners Julie man and Caren nortman
and um and then amazing group of of
investors including Jen Garner and Uso
aduba and America Ferrera Eva
Longoria 14 former US Women's National
team players and um yeah it's been the
most fun and the team is incredible and
maybe like little girls can grow up how
we didn't we we always watched male
athletes generally like it was rare when
you saw a female athlete and it was
always a gymnast exactly was nothing
wrong with but it was always that well
it's a given that women will can look up
to m athletes and so the opposite should
be true too that little boys can look up
to female athletes as well as little
girls of course and then like you said
those and to see them playing strong you
know we're strong team sports where like
hair and makeup isn't important or like
what they're wearing isn't important
like and they're working together as a
team and um they come in all shapes and
sizes like you don't have to be a
certain height to play soccer like
there's some tiny ones there's some tall
ones there's you know it's like kind of
amazing it's just this incredible
inclusive
I loved playing soccer growing up what
did did you play sports growing up did
you like it at all
oh didn't I wish I think I'm just
competitive yeah in my spirit do you get
passionate at least at games oh yeah but
I don't know like any of the right words
but you know yeah you're just like that
was a bad call I don't know what it was
but look at you oh my God I'm like yeah
exactly I didn't
oh I didn't see that I actually did not
I have not seen that picture till just
now I didn't know were putting that ter
actually we could be friends from this
photo alone that is me at a game I just
get very into it and it's amazing to see
people excel in sports I just think I'm
not I wasn't ever like a great athlete I
was average but like I love watching
people excel at what they're great at
and to see what the human body is
capable of in that situ is so cool to me
um well you like games I know cuz you
beat me at one here the last time you
were here it's fine um do you want to
play another game I just want Redemption
that's what I want I love games too okay
okay okay I'm going to kick your ass
okay um it's time it's time for a
rematch next everybody we're going to be
right
[Music]
[Applause]
back thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home